hier a eu lieu l'hommage solennel du
président et du gouvernement ou quatre
policiers les victimes de mickaël larpe
ont suivi des auditions auprès des
parlementaires du ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner et le
moins qu'on puisse dire contrairement à
celui ci répétant que les choses soient
claires au moins dix fois c'est que de
nombreuses zones d'ombré demeurent à
commencer par la responsabilité de tel
ou tel dans cette tragédie et au point
de se demander si on trouvera finalement
des coupables dans cette affaire
est-ce que c'est l'impression vous avez
un peu christian macario qu'au fond il
n'y a pas eu il n'y aura pas vraiment de
sanctions et s'il devait y en avoir qui
devrait elle viser prioritairement
non parce que la chose politique s'est
emparée de cette affaire gravissime et
que bien entendu on est passé sur un
autre terrain frappé castaner dans la
situation se trouve
emmanuel macron ce serait encore
affaiblir son propre système
mais je pense que ce serait aussi une
réponse insuffisante et voire ambiguë
pourquoi parce que paradoxalement malgré
les lacunes frappante est assez
inconcevable de ce ministre de
l'intérieur non seulement sur cette
affaire là mais sur d'autres champs
malgré le fait qu'il justifierait
largement une sanction de nature
démocratique
c'est quelque part il faut y penser
donnez raison aussi aux islamistes que
de le détrôner ce serait leur offrir une
victoire est là on est pris dans une
nasse les démocraties se trouve
complètement piéger par le caractère si
j'ose dire cette fois-ci ordinaire de ce
type de terrorisme là parce que michael
harpon qui a commis ce quadruple crime
était un individu socialiser à la
différence des cas précédents
c'était un employé intégrer parfaitement
et donc toutes les grilles de lecture
qu'on nous a proposé jusqu'ici de la
théorie du loup solitaire opère dans
radikal
cher à hans magnus enzensberger
excellent petit opuscule d'ailleurs pas
par d'autres pour d'autres raisons
tout cela n'est pas fonctionnel ni
opérationnel pour expliquer ce qui se
passe car nous n'avons pas affaire à des
individus et je crois que depuis le
début on se trompe on perd du temps mais
à une idéologie et il est beaucoup plus
difficile pour une démocratie de
combattre une biologique de flics et si
j'ose dire des individus et de les
surveiller ces termes qui partent dans
tous les sens des radicalisations
radicalise etc ni n'ont aucun caractère
fonctionnel
cette idéologie s'est installée et s'est
installé dans la vie quotidienne
ordinaire de nos démocraties
là il s'agit d'un épisode extrêmement
dramatique avec quatre morts mais il se
passe dans les hôpitaux dans le métro
dans l'est la restauration scolaire ou
même avec la complicité de la boucherie
française au sujet de la viande halal il
se passe une pénétration qui évoque de
mon point de vue inexorablement le titre
prophétique de l'excellent livre de
michel houellebecq soumission il ya
quelque chose qui est entré à
l'intérieur au coeur même de démocratie
et pas seulement au coeur de la
préfecture de police
et ce n'est plus des radicaliser des
individus isolés est jugé dangereux dont
il s'agit c'est vraiment de d'organiser
un front démocratique une réponse
démocratique à ces idéologies là et si
on prend des parallèles historiques
lorsque le des vocations lui ont eu à
lutter contre des idéologies meurtrières
ça nous renvoie la seconde guerre
mondiale évidemment on s'est bien aperçu
que la notion de fins de fanatisme était
très difficile à combattre
de la part des principes démocratiques
donc je crois que par lesdits dhr où
cette inflation verbal cette inflation
d'incantation à mon avis ne constituent
absolument pas la réponse
donc pour finir je crois pas qu hélas là
le limogeage du très responsable
ministre de l'intérieur soit en soi une
idée bonne ni suffisante il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin et je ne trouve pas
que le discours de monsieur macron et
répondu à l'ampleur du défi je n'ai pas
ce type d'accord avec l'idée que c'est
pas au sein de la police ou du
gouvernement qu'il faut sanctionner des
gens mais il faut sanctionner des gens
comme un moment donné c'est moi je pense
qu'il faut sanctionner il ya quand même
une chaîne de responsabilités c'est à
dire qu'à un moment où quelqu'un qui est
signalé pour apologie du terrorisme
puisque au moment d'aller de charlie
hebdo il a quand même dit c'est bien
fait c'est pas rien et c'est quand même
un délit d'apologie de terrorisme canton
un membre des services de renseignement
qui se rend coupable d'un délit
d'apologie du terrorisme et qui on le
sait qu'ils ne se soient pas remonter au
de la chaîne de carémeau la voilà je
pense qu'il ya quand même un vrai
dysfonctionnements et que évidemment il
faut qu' il ya quelque part des
responsabilités et des sanctions qu'ils
soient prises je rappelle d'ailleurs
qu'à eu un précédent puisque lors de
l'attentât de marseille en 2016
en 2017
on avait rappelé de ce terroriste qui
avait à la gare saint-charles égorgé
deux jeunes filles qui venaient d'être
libérées d'un centre de rétention où ils
étaient ils avaient été enfermés pendant
quelques jours pour un délit après des
multiples délits il a été relâché parce
que le centre est est saturée bien le
préfet a sauté et gérard collomb a
renvoyé le préfet du rhône donc dans ce
cas là on avait pris les sanctions
est ce qu'il faut je prends de censurer
des bouches du rhône où est-ce qu'il
faut prendre des sanctions pareil de ce
même type
je le crois qu'il ya un moment où
falloir aussi envoyé des signale que les
personnes en responsabilité qui n'ont
pas appris les bonnes décisions doivent
être aussi puni évidemment je suis
d'accord avec vous ça ne réglera pas du
tout problème mais il faut quand même
envoyé le signal que le relâchement et
la baisse de la garde de la vigilance ne
sont pas acceptables et que les
fonctionnaires qu'une de l'éthane
doivent dans un garde et cette vigilance
là est brune serait ce que pour rassurer
la population
il faut donner un signal après
évidemment je suis totalement d'accord
avec vous donc on va être de longue
haleine c'est un combat qui ne ne peut
se résumer en cendre strict point de vue
sécuritaire c'est un combat en effet
idéologique j'allais dire même
civilisationnel qui se gagnera pas à
coups simplement de limogeage et de et
de mesures sécuritaires qui est comme
l'a dit très justement alexis brézet
alors justement une lutte contre le jeu
voulait emmener avec vous peut-être
lucile schmid
alexis brézet dans un éditorial
retentissant du figaro lundi parlé de
déni islamistes qui s'illustre notamment
par parce que l'on sait maintenant sur
la situation de l'imam de gonesse auprès
duquel se rendait à mickaël larpe ont
écouté ce que disait hier sur le figure
en laye françois pupponi député du val
d'oise et ancien maire de sarcelles
cet imam avant d'être à gonesse était à
sarcelles et donc nous allons faire en
sorte de avec les responsables
d'ailleurs de la mosquée d'une des
mosquées de sarcelles de l'évincer de la
ville car il commençait à avoir des
attitudes extrêmement dangereuse pour la
communauté musulmane de la ville et
lequel il recrutait des jeunes en
particulier jeunes délinquants dans les
quartiers il commençait à prendre
beaucoup de place il mettait les anciens
dehors il faisait rentrer des salafistes
et les services du renseignement tereos
savez pour en parler regular vrai que il
savait cet individu dangereux
il a même été
à l'époque sous le coup d'une obligation
de quitter le territoire français
exactement qui n'a jamais été mise en
oeuvre
des propos qui sont confirmées par
christophe castaner lui même lors de son
émission ailleurs écouté son audition
pendant été admis en france le 11
décembre 2014 début 2015
il a fait l'objet d'une oqtf qui n'a pas
été exécuté je ne sais pas pourquoi ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que deux
puits dans le cadre de la commission
départementale que vous avez évoqué avec
des élus désignés par l'association des
maires de chaque département il a été
décidé de lui accorder un titre valable
parce qu'il a un enfant et qu'il s'est
marié le cil suite à ce que les
sanctions devraient pas toucher prix
notamment ceux qui ont laissé cet imam
en france prêcher alors qu'ils devaient
être expulsés et prêcher un islam
radical
je pense qu'il ya dans ce qu'on dit
christian makarian et au génie bastien
il ya deux choses de registre qui
doivent être associés aujourd'hui du
côté du politique
il ya à la fois le registre de la chaîne
de responsabilités à la fois
administrative et politique
et puis il ya la question de la lutte
sur le projet c'est à dire que et je
tiens à dire que je suis d'accord avec
christian marcarian sur le fait qu'il ya
une idéologie d'islamisme radical moi le
terme du radical jeu le jeu ne le sors
pas du débat je sais pas s'il ya des
radicaliser ou pas mais il ya un
islamisme radical il ya des musulmans
ça a été ça ressort de ce que disait
françois pupponi qui sont expulsés des
mosquées par d'autres musulmans plus
radicaux donc ya pas peut-être qu'il
faut que je le rappelle quand même ici
il n'ya pas que des musulmans radicaux
et il ya aujourd'hui une radicalisation
justement voilà qu'on utilise le terme
d' islam salafiste vous met donc ça
c'est quand même utile de le rappeler
parce que la question de mettre tous les
musulmans dans le même sac alors qu'on a
cinq millions de musulmans en france
c'est un vrai sujet la communauté
musulmane ça fait partie prenante de la
société française donc je crois qu'il ya
à la fois la chaîne de responsabilités
et moi ce qui me semble c'est que faire
sauter la tête de castaner qui n'était
pas là en 2015 quand mickaël larpe on
profère ces termes c'est totalement
inopérant et je suis d'accord avec
christian macario sur le fait que là il
ya une sorte de deux postures
politiciennes que je réprouve
profondément en revanche je crois qu'il
faut pas toujours faire sauter les
ministres on peut aussi sanctionner les
fonctionnaires c'est à dire que
si ça a été dit oralement et qui a pas
eu un suivi de la procédure
ça c'est un problème est là moi je
serais pour faire une enquête
administrative approfondie pour
identifier pourquoi ça n'a pas été
suivie d'effet parce que vous savez le
problème que lorsqu'on appartient à
l'administration c'est que on a des amis
on a des pères on a on a des communauté
de destin si je puis dire et ça conduit
parfois à relativiser des signaux qui
sont des signaux forts être un lanceur d
alerte sur les questions de mickaël
larpe on a dit ça alors que c'était un
bon collègue il était atteint de surdité
il était socialiser quelque part c'est
quelque chose on hésite davantage quand
quelqu'un est socialisé par exemple à le
dénoncer
lorsqu'il est père de famille est donc
là il ya des éléments de psychologie du
groupe qui à mon avis doivent être
soigneusement analysée avant de dire on
fait sauter castaner la deuxième chose
par rapport à cette histoire de
reconduite à la frontière de l'imam
c'est que c'est quand même scandaleux
qu'elle n'ait pas été fait et c'est peu
de le dire mais ensuite lorsqu'il a un
enfant il y là il est l'objet d'un titre
de il reçoit un titre de séjour
comme si d'une certaine manière ça va
c'était deux mondes parallèles c'est à
dire qu' il était l'objet d'une
reconduite à la frontière et ensuite
s'il a un enfant et d'un titre de séjour
et on passe on passe la question la
reconduite à la frontière apparemment
sous silence par pertes et profits ça
c'est un problème c'est un problème
d'incohérence dans le droit mais le
droit aujourd'hui fait si vous avez un
enfant en france vous avez droit à un
titre de séjour
donc il faut qu'on raisonne aussi sur la
question juridique et qu'on ne soit pas
seulement en train de dire y'a qu'à faut
qu'on
dans ce cas là il faut avoir un débat au
parlement changer la loi et introduire
des éléments sur lesquels s'il ya eu un
précédent de ce type là on n'a pas le
droit de délivrer un titre de séjour à
quelqu'un qui a un enfant ans né en
france
ce qui pose évidemment des tas de
problèmes de précédents et il faut aussi
qu'on imagine cette complexité
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau sont nicolas
quand vous êtes un peu spécialiste de
sousse us que la loi sur encadrent un
petit peu haut sur prothèse c'est la
manière ce genre de ce genre de cas
parce que les policiers de 10 à
majoritairement en disant nous on fait
notre métier mais après la justice
annule certains ses ambivalences que
disait monsieur magail on sait que la
loi c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous ce
qui nous définit c'est ce qui fait que
nous sommes une civilisation et c'est en
même temps une des principales
faiblesses la procédure elle est là pour
protéger les libertés et en même temps
effectivement parfois en termes
d'efficacité ça achoppe sur le cul tf1
mots quand même parce que moi quand
j'entends le ministre l'intérieur venir
je ne sais pas enfin il sait très bien
pourquoi locuteurs n'a pas été appliquée
parce que le pays d'origine de cet imam
a refusé tout simplement de le reprendre
donc il faut dire les choses clairement
et ça pose aussi la question de nos
relations diplomatiques sur ces sujets
là avec ce que nous appelons nos
partenaires algériens et c'est un vrai
sujet diplomatique deuxième chose quand
même vous parliez d'un combat politique
et moi je suis complètement d'accord
c'est d'abord un combat politique avant
d'être un combat sécuritaire même si les
deux peuvent aller ensemble des gens
tout j'entends françois pupponi député
de sarcelles qui a longtemps été maire
de cette ville
on rentre dans une campagne électorale
pour les municipales
moi j'attends que ce combat politique on
parle aussi de la gestion
communautariste d'un certain nombre de
villes en france par des élus de droite
comme de gauche
l'allèle centre et du centre la question
n'est pas uniquement celle de des
agissements de tel ou tel le zii mamou
tel ou tel groupe religieux il ya une
responsabilité politique et on a une
campagne électorale qui va commencer
mettons ce sujet au coeur du débat
comment est-ce qu'on gère nos villes
aujourd'hui nos politiques de la ville
et le fait religieux dans la ville
troisième chose sur toujours sur la
mosquée de gonesse moi ce que je trouve
très intéressant dans le témoignage
françois pupponi s'est nous dire il
était à sarcelles on l'a viré de
sarcelles pardonnez moi l'expression
il est allé à gonesse et il il a pu
récupérer une mosquée c'est à dire que
je me souviens en novembre 2015
on avait commencé à parler la fermeture
de certains lieux de culte parce que
finalement c'est patent l'imam qui pose
un problème c'est qu'on trouve encore
des lieux de culte pour accueillir des
imams radicaliser là aussi l'état il a
certainement un rôle à jouer donc on est
à mon avis sur une
[Musique]
une échelle de sanctions et de et
d'action qui beaucoup plus large que
celle que nous propose le gouvernement
aujourd'hui jo et qu'on continue son
problème des mosquées notamment avec
vous christian makarian qui est aussi un
aspect site de religion juste avant la
question twitter était faut-il
sanctionner les responsables politiques
policiers et religieux pour les
dysfonctionnements nature et la
préfecture de paris la réponse est oui à
79% non à 21%
nada nous dit un responsable quel qu'il
soit doit être sanctionné s'il a failli
à son devoir et récompensés quand il
honore sa profession chacun d'eux
s'engage quand il prend des
responsabilités macabre nitot de façon
symbolique il est évident que quelqu'un
devra être sanctionné l'utilité la
légitimité de la sanction ça fera
l'objet de débats john challen la
fonction seul sans changement d'approché
la méthode n'est pas très efficace
c'est vrai que tout ça on est dans une
sorte de flou joueurs qu'on revienne sur
les sur l'histoire des mosquées parce
que christophe castaner hier à un peu
perdu en dix ans on a fermé sept
mosquées salafistes quand on sait qui en
a je crois
80 c'est assez dérisoire cet après midi
mohamed sifaoui a fait une série de
tweets en annonçant que le cfcm selon
lui allait proposer au ministère
l'intérieur à christophe castaner un
conseil de l'ordre des imams est ce que
c'est ça qui manquaient jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pour encadrer c'est à dire
que c'est le message l'intérieur qui
délivrera effectivement comme instance
légitime d une sorte de d'autorisation
de prêcher et ceux qui ne l'auront pas
dans les mosquées françaises bien
entendu ne pourrons pas continuer à
prêcher est-ce que c'est enfin la
solution qu'on attend depuis des années
cet encadrement pas du tout pas du tout
parce que le cfcm lui-même est une sorte
de parlement intra musulmans dans lequel
les différentes tendances de liste
hommes s'expriment et il y en a qui sont
radicales
non pas peut-être au sens le plus
dangereux loupé le meurtrier ou mais il
y a énormément de tensions à l'intérieur
de cette instance
donc ça fait maintenant un quart de
siècle qu'on tourne autour de cette idée
d' islam à la française et ça n'aboutit
pas non plus pourquoi parce que
fondamentalement nous sommes tributaires
de l'arrivée de ces islam
de ces imams pardon en provenance de
pays étrangers on ne contrôle pas du
tout leur provenance
dans l'idéal les imams devraient être
français provenir de défenses et avec un
diplôme universitaire afférents qui à ce
jour n'existe pas un
donc tant que no buteront sur les
limites de la laïcité
la laïcité n'a jamais été conçu pour
l'islam mais la laïcité de 1905 a été
inventé pour que des catholiques
incroyants et des catholiques croyant
cohabitent les tous les deux étaient
catholiques des catholiques totalement
athée ou des catholiques agnostique et
puis 10-4 y croyant ça n'est pas qu'il
faut changer la loi 1901 ça veut dire
que la loi de 1905 ne répond pas aux
défis
à l'heure actuelle qui est le suivant
partout et c'est pareil en allemagne où
un attentat s'est produit cet après-midi
pas plus tard que ce après midi dans la
vie de la halle partout où des
communautés musulmanes importantes se
sont implantées en europe
la théorie islamistes tentent de les
fractures et pour que les éléments les
plus fragiles mentalement ou les plus
excités où les plus énervés puissent
devenir des acteurs agissants et
potentiellement des criminels donc il
faut absolument que l'islam soit régi de
façon beaucoup plus autoritaire et et il
faut prendre des décisions dans ce
domaine là ça ne sert à rien de parler
d'hydre islamistes
je crois que tant que nous aurons des
islams dont des imans pardon dont la
provenance n'est pas contrôlable dont la
formation n'est pas contrôlable
nous laisserons les musulmans de france
aux prises à ceux qui déchirent tous les
pays arabes où tout l'islam du maire
général c'est-à-dire une lutte entre les
radicaux et les autres la france est
aujourd'hui l'otage d'une guerre entre
musulmans qui a été importé en france
c'est cela qu'il faut arrêter donc la
première chose c'est de couper la
provenance
tout ce qui provient de l'étranger en
matière de formation et de prêches c'est
très important
juste une précision je compte l'attentât
en allemagne n'était pas forcément
reconnus comme islamiste pour la droite
il ya eu avant ça quelques jours un
attentat avec un camion donc celui là ça
me paraît pas tout aussi mais bon quoi
qu'il en soit l'idée ja l'idée selon
laquelle on serait sorti de la phase la
plus vive est la plus dramatique il faut
de 2015 est totalement fausse la preuve
en est au coeur de la préfecture investi
les noms mais je suis assez assez
d'accord avec vous sur l'idée que je
pense que l'état aujourd'hui ne naît pas
assez n'est ce pas assez de son pouvoir
de contrainte et d'ailleurs
enfin toute l'histoire enfin toute
l'histoire de la france c'est l'état qui
s'ingèrent dans le religieux est qui et
qui met fin d'ailleurs incertaine
c'était une dissidence religieuse au
coeur que ce soit avec les protestants
d'ailleurs jusqu'au catholique et même
aux juifs puisqu'ils ont la création du
consistoire qui n'existait pas dans
judaïsme qui a été créé toutes pièces
par l'état français point même où le
mettre donc il n'existe pas dans la peau
ou encore sur les religions juste le
consistoire n'existe pas donc on dit oui
il n'ya pas de clergé en islam mais on
peut aussi créer un clergé et je pense
que l'étape si vous en donne les moyens
peut aussi mettre de l'ordre dans la
dans la religion musulmane sur le
territoire français qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement c'est vrai la loi 1905
moi je pense n'est pas aujourd'hui
suffisamment adapté à répondre à cet
enjeu là parce que cette loi 1905 était
fait pour séparer les catholiques de la
public là où il s'agit finalement
d'intégrer l'islam à la france c'est
quand même totalement différent c'est à
dire que là on parlait d'une séparation
là on parle d'une intégration et moi je
pense qu en effet il faut il faut couper
en effet tout tout lien entre
les murs enfin les imams et des pays
étrangers car c'est ça c'est l'un des
principaux problèmes est créée en effet
une forme de l'islam à la française en
se donnant véritablement les moyens
parce que ça a été tentée en effet vous
l'avez dit mais sans moyens sans moyens
de coercition et sans moyens de
financement donc c'est la première
vraiment s'en donner les moyens
oui moi moi cet islam à la française on
entend parler depuis trente ans jean
pierre chevènement a été l'un des
premiers je crois en parler et moi il se
trouve qu'au début des années 90 j'étais
en algérie et que à l'époque on parlait
déjà du problème de la formation des
imams en france avec l'idée qu'ils
venaient de l'étranger donc ça fait 30
ans au fond ce qui est très important et
on parle de la responsabilité de l'état
est de la france c'est de s'apercevoir
que si ça fait 30 ans qu'on parle de la
formation des imams et ça fait 30 ans
qu'ils viennent de l'étranger
nous avons aussi une responsabilité en
tant que partie prenante en france
société française est à français
français dans le fait qu'il n'ya pas
d'imam formés en france pourquoi parce
que nous avons une relation d'une forte
ambivalence par rapport à la présence
des musulmans en france
nous pensons à la fois qu'ils sont là et
en même temps nous avons peur qu'ils
soient des terroristes donc et toute la
décennie 90 a montré une vraie
ambivalence là dessus et je pense que
comme musulmans de france on vit aussi
une forme d'ambivalence à dire se
reconnaîtront comme français se sentent
on français et c est cette question de
l'ambivalence il faut aujourd'hui la
traiter je suis d'accord avec l'idée de
la formation d'imams en france en
revanche sur l'organisation elle même et
je crois que le geste de formation des
imams est quelque chose de fort mais il
faut quand même savoir que la religion
musulmane c'est aujourd'hui combien
christian makarian faisait référence en
disant qu'il ya une guerre d islam entre
eux selon que vous êtes un musulman
algérien marocain malien pakistanais
vous avez une pratique de l'islam
extrêmement différente mais les as du
nationalisme est par ailleurs la
pratique se fait beaucoup de manière
individuelle c'est à dire que ceux qui
vont prier à la mosquée d'abord ya pas
assez de place pour prier
donc il ya un sujet des lieux il ya
peut-être trop de mosquées salafistes
mais ya pas assez de mosquées en général
donc ça il faut quand même le dire
et la deuxième chose c'est que donc
souvent pris chez soi donc moi ce que je
crois c'est qu'on a un vrai sujet
effectivement il faut poser un acte
politique en disant on combattra le
terrorisme islamiste
on combattra cette idéologie est par
ailleurs nous ferons en sorte que la
question d'un islam qui soit parti
francs
de la société française en formant des
imams en france mais en donnant aussi
une place aux musulmans en reconnaissant
que tout musulman n'est pas un danger il
faut que cela s'accompagne d'un discours
structure en l'absence de discours
récurrent fait qu'aujourd'hui
d'une certaine façon la communauté
musulmane n'a pas aujourd'hui beaucoup
de courage non plus parfois pour
condamner le terrorisme et on a le
sentiment d'une espèce d'ambivalence du
côté la société française et du côté de
la communauté musulmane française cette
ambivalence doit être combattue des deux
côtés ils vont ils pas fait de votre
avis avec une bizarrerie ahurissante
propre à la france qui est le statut de
la mosquée de paris qui dépend de
l'algérie pour sa nomination puisque
c'est un fait colonial c'est une
création du maréchal lyautey et que
c'est la société des habous ce qui en
est la gestionnaire
tout ça sur le sol français avec un
bâtiment français et nous aimons tous la
mosquée de paris qui est un lieu
charmant et nous n'avons absolument rien
contre la liberté de culte des musulmans
mais est il concevable qu'il y a encore
des ambiguïtés post coloniale de cette
nature là je veux dire il faut clarifier
les choses et il faut qu'au niveau du
discours des hommes politiques au lieu
de parler d'hydre de monstres à sept
têtes etc
il y une décision claire et nette qu'ils
soient prises il n'est pas inconcevable
qu'il doit qu'il faille avoir un diplôme
d' imam pour exercer dans une mosquée
légalement et qu'en dehors de ça se soit
déclaré illégales les séminaires
catholique procède comme ça
sauf que c'est l'église qui expulse tous
ceux qui ne sont pas habilités par
l'église à le faire alors que l'église
fait le boulot pour elle-même la l'islam
n'étant pas structuré de cette façon là
il va falloir aider les musulmans a
retrouvé le chemin de leur spiritualité
et non pas le chemin de la porosité à
l'idéologie islamique c'est rendre
service à tout le monde que de faire
preuve de ce courage là je pense qu'il
faut aussi dire
que on a un système en france pardon
d'être un peu divergent sur le sujet qui
a permis quand même d'intégrer dans la
société française des millions de
citoyens français de confession
musulmane et c'est ça aussi c'est ce
modèle là qui est attaquée aujourd'hui
ce qui dérange énormément nos ennemis
salafistes islamistes radicaux
c'est que pour une grande partie l'islam
est soluble dans le système occidental
européen et y compris français avec la
loi de 1905 il ya une guerre aussi
idéologique sur ce terrain là parce que
depuis des années avec des échecs avec
des reculades avec parfois du reniement
mais quand même finale il ya des
millions de français musulmans qui
vivent en paix sur ce seul là et qui
sont intégrés dans la société française
et quand on voit des jeunes femmes de
confession musulmane qui progresse dans
la société qui se marient avec des
hommes qui ne sont pas de leur
confession parce que ça arrive de plus
en plus oui il ya des reculs du
radicalisme musulman qui a lieu
aujourd'hui en france c'est à dire que
il ya un double il ya un double schéma
le radicalisme islamiste est devenu un
sujet polarisant dans le débat politique
français et heureusement et c'est bien
et d'ailleurs on voit y compris emmanuel
macron qui est avancé mais dans la
communauté musulmane finalement ce
radicalisme islamiste d'une certaine
manière je ne nie pas qu'il régresse
jeudi qu'il y a des forces très fortes
et positives notamment chez les jeunes
musulmans français notamment chez les
femmes qui avancent de manière assez
positif mais non mais je sais très bien
qu'on va pas être d'accord de mallarmé
puisqu'une manifestations sont
organisées place saint michel par les
citoyens musulmans de france donc on
verra s'il ya du monde c'est peut-être
pas les joueurs ça valait plus
représentent comme vous avez les chips
sur comment dire la jeune musulman
france quand on pratique beaucoup plus
rigoristes et beaucoup plus
une orthopraxie beaucoup plus visible
que nous laver leurs parents et leurs
grands-parents donc je ne serai pas tout
à fait d'accord avec vous pour voir des
divisions au sein de la division mais en
tout cas ce qu'on pensait que quand on
disait en 89 ont la fin du voile que le
jean aurait raison du voile ballon
revient que celle inverse qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs même les plus diplômés saleh
faire une plus diplômés qui portent le
voile au revoir merci à tous les pilotes
comme c'était pour tous était bavard
guébriant nous nous n'aurons pas parlé
d' adama traoré
c'est un individu d'aulnay-sous-bois si
je voulais faire une manifestation en
l'honneur de michael à fond et pour une
fois christophe castaner et bien voilà a
réagi avec fermeté en interdisant cette
manif a rappelé le préfet était prêt à
l'autoriser parenthèse qui était quand
même assez aberrant
en tout cas nous ne parlons pas de cet
avis du j'en suis très content merci à
tous les caps
deuxième sujet qui revient souvent
depuis deux ans d'un point de vue donald
trump dans un courrier adressé au
congrès l'avocat la maison blur de la
maison blanche patsy l'open explique que
le président refuse toute collaboration
avec l'anc est ouverte en vue d'une
procédure pour le destituer à la suite
des révélations d'un lanceur d alerte
sur une conversation entre trains p le
président ukrainien zélande